bei uns ist bildchef Reporter Peter
Thiede Peter du hast auch die ganze
Pressekonferenz verfolgt dein erster
Eindruck ein so wie Nadja das gesagt hat
ein erholter Kanzler ein bewusst auch so
auftreten da Kanzler ich würde mal sagen
er hat den Yoga Kanzler gegeben also
wirklich Entspannung in Zeiten von
Krisen er hat quasi auch vielleicht
bewussten Kontrapunkt gesetzt zum
Beispiel zu den Grünen die vor sozialen
Unruhen waren und die davon ausgehen
dass es tatsächlich ein sehr sehr heißer
Herbst auch auf der Straße werden werden
könnte da hat er den den Kanzler der
frisch aus dem Urlaub kommt gegeben und
den Familienvater der irgendwie sagt
leute macht euch mal keine Sorgenkinder
jeder kriegt eine Kugel Eis das war so
der rote Faden der dadurch geführt hat
heute und man muss sagen er hat diese
eine Stunde 47 die die ganze
Veranstaltung gedauert hat tatsächlich
patzafrei über die Bühne gebracht
allerdings auch wirklich fast schon
schamfrei bei Angela Merkel gab es immer
mal so ein lachmomenten komischen
irgendwie den hat es nicht gegeben okay
wir haben wir haben Krise und Scholz ist
halt ein bisschen schwierig also fast
zwei Stunden von Journalisten sich alle
natürlich hart nachfragen zum Teil das
ist ein das ist ein Format in dem
gewinnt immer der Kanzler weil jeder
Journalist hat eine Frage eine Nachfrage
erste Frage nicht beantworten zweite
Frage nicht richtig beantworten schon
bist du raus und der Kollege ist das
mikrol ist das mikrofonlos dazu kommt
dann noch die Auslandspresse die auch
noch mal ganz spezielle Fragen hat zu
Arabien zur zu anderen Sachen wo der
Kanzler immer mal durchatmen kann wo er
sich noch mal überlegen kann wenn jetzt
noch mal eine Frage kommt was sage ich
denn dann darauf also gehen wir mal
durch ja wir wollen auf die erste Kugel
Eis schauen so wie du es genannt hast da
gab es nämlich gleich mal ein
Versprechen ein sogenannten
merkel-moment
also gucken was müssen wir machen damit
diejenigen die arbeiten aber nicht so
Geld genug verdienen dass sie die
teureren heizspreise und Wohnungspreise
finanzieren können unterstützen das ist
die wohngeldfrage wir sollten überlegen
was ist jetzt mit der bürgergeldreform
das richtige wir sollten überlegen was
können wir tun im Hinblick auf rendern
und Studenten was können wir tun für
diejenigen die
wenig verdienen und deshalb von den
Steuerentlastungen nicht so viel haben
und was können wir für die tun bei denen
die steuererlastung genau das richtige
Instrument ist dann rechnen wir das
zusammen und gucken ob wir uns das
leisten können mein Gefühl sagt wir
werden das können
schwupps da ist der Merkel Moment wir
schaffen das
so wir können uns das leisten der
Kanzler sagt also er zieht alles auf was
auf dem Tisch ist was aus seiner Partei
kommt was von den Grünen kommt und auch
was Christian Lindner vorgestellt hat
Steuerentlastung und er sagt am Ende wir
werden es zusammenrechnen und mein
Gefühl sagt mir da wir können das wir
können uns das leisten das ist ein
Merkel im Moment bei Frage 3 schon
relativ früh hat er ein Versprechen
abgegeben an die deutschen wir können
uns diese Krise leisten wir werden sie
dadurch führen Geld ist für alle da und
das ist auch eine Ansage in in seiner
Ampel rein jeder kriegt ja seine Kugel
Eis die Grünen die SPD und die FDP in
unmittelbaren Zusammenhang damit
natürlich auch die Angst vor sozialen
Unruhen du hast gesagt die Grünen Namen
ist angesprochen kommt die heizkrise im
Winter muss man frieren kann man sich
keinen Strom mehr lassen auch dazu hat
er sich geäußert werden
unsere Wirtschaftslage ist ja
gegenwärtig trotz dieser Schwierigkeiten
davon gekennzeichnet dass wir eine hohe
Beschäftigung haben und sie sogar weiter
steigt und deshalb glaube ich haben wir
alle Chancen gut durch diese Zeit zu
kommen auch wenn es schwierig wird klar
wer muss man fast nicht sagen der
Kanzler sagt wir kommen da durch aber es
wird nicht einfach dass es quasi das was
über den Winter und das nächste Jahr
sagt er spricht nicht nur über dem über
den Winter also es kann dauern die
nächsten Monate werden nicht leicht aber
sagen wir so rum niemand stürzt total ab
es werden viele Leute Abrutschen in
Sozialhilfe nicht in Sozialhilfe zum
Beispiel in Wohngeld in staatliche
Leistung die bisher nie darauf
angewiesen waren aber da kannst du auch
die Kohle reicht aber es soll ja helfen
geben da hat sich ja zum Beispiel auch
Christian Lindner jetzt ein Schönes
steuerentlastungspaket ausgedacht da hat
er sich aus geäußert aber ich glaube
Christian Lindner wird nicht gefallen
haben was er da gesagt hat
und das will ich auch hier noch einmal
wiederholen das gilt für ganz ganz viele
Bürger und Bürger es gibt mehr um
diejenigen die 28 verdienen 3200 Euro
brutto im Monat 4000 Euro für die das
alles große Herausforderungen sind und
deshalb ist klar dass du dem Gesamtpaket
dass wir ergreifen werden sicherlich
auch steuerlich Entlastungsmaßnahmen
dazu gehören der Finanzminister hat
seinen Beitrag zu den notwendigen
Überlegungen dazu gestern vorgestellt
ich finde das sehr sehr hilfreich
Finanzminister hat seinen Beitrag
gestern vorgelegt man muss sich immer
vor Augen führen dass der Chef der FDP
der Bundesvorsitzende der freien
demokratischen Partei Deutschlands und
Finanzminister dieses Landes gestern in
sein Ministerium eine große
Pressekonferenz abgehalten hat und
verkündet hat 48 Millionen Deutsche
werden steuerlich entlastet werden
der Kanzler findet das hilfreich und er
hat ihn dann quasi auch eingenommen und
hat ihn auch einsortiert also das was
Christian Lindner gestern groß gemacht
hat vor der Pressekonferenz des
Bundeskanzlers heute hat der
Bundeskanzler dann eingeordnet in
Wohngeld diese Sachen Rentner und
Studenten und steuerliche Entlassung
also Christian Lindner ist ins Glied
gepfiffen worden hat einen wichtigen
Beitrag geleistet darf ihn auch
weitermachen aber es ist nur ein Stein
von ganz vielen kleinen Christian
Lindner so dann ging es natürlich auch
um das Thema cumex ziemlich brisant muss
man sagen
Steuerhinterziehung in Millionen
Milliardenhöhe und da ging es natürlich
auch um die Frage was wusste was weißes
stolz steuertricksereien genau
ich habe zu diesen Dingen ja sehr
umfangreich und viele Stunden lang
Stellung genommen und werde das wieder
tun ich habe
die Auskünfte gegeben die möglich sind
aber ich will gerne Ihre Frage als
Gelegenheit benutzen einmal auf
folgendes freundlich hinzuweisen das ist
jetzt seit zweieinhalb Jahren ein Thema
der Journalisten für alle möglichen die
an dem Thema arbeiten auch für den
Ausschuss in Hamburg es sind unglaublich
viele Personen gehört worden es sind
unglaublich viele Akten studiert worden
und wenn man jetzt die
Presseberichterstattung über die
jeweiligen Anhörungen anderes verfolgt
dann ist immer das Ergebnis es hat keine
Beeinflussung durch die Politik gegeben
was die Entscheidung betrifft ich bin
sicher dass diese Erkenntnis nicht mehr
verändert werden wird nach zweieinhalb
Jahren ist das ganz klar
ja also vielleicht muss man auch ganz
kurz sagen entweder Scholz hat ja selber
auch schon aussagen müssen es geht um
seine Zeit als er
Regierender Bürgermeister erster
Bürgermeister in Hamburg war es geht um
die warburgbank der angeblich mithilfe
der Politik fast 50 Millionen an Steuern
erlassen worden sein sollen Rückzahlung
die eigentlich nötig gewesen im Raum das
Olaf Scholz daran aktiv beteiligt war
dass sie die Warburg Bank entweder
direkt oder indirekt an ihm gewandt hat
und er dafür gesorgt hat dass die
Hamburger oder das unter ihm zumindest
dafür gesorgt worden ist dass die
Hamburger Steuerbehörden eine später
nicht mehr zu haltende Entscheidung
getroffen haben nämlich dieser wirklich
angesehen in Hamburger Privatbank und
sehr einflussreichen Privatbank 47
Millionen Euro zu erlassen so Olaf
Scholz sagt daran wird sich nichts mehr
ändern an den Erkenntnissen man muss
dazu sagen dass der Kanzler mit diesem
Satz eigentlich nur sagt an meine
Erinnerungslücken wird sich nichts
ändern ich werde mich auch in Zukunft
nicht an wichtige Gespräche die ich
jetzt Hamburger Bürgermeister geführt
habe erinnern können mein be ist
geleistet nämlich keiner nämlich Olaf
Scholz leidet in diesem zweieinhalb
Jahren hier auch
Untersuchungsausschüssen ausgesagt hat
und jetzt demnächst wieder aussagen muss
immer unter Gedächtnislücken wenn es
entscheidend wird kann sich der
Bundeskanzler früher nicht an seine Zeit
und ein Gespräche als Hamburger
Regierender Bürgermeister Erinnerung
oder erster Bürgermeister und daran wird
sich halt nichts ändern das sagt der
Kanzler hier mit klipp und klar ich
werde mich nicht weiter erinnern die
Journalisten die können sich natürlich
erinnern haben dementsprechend natürlich
noch mal ein bisschen nachgehakt und
nachgefragt haben wir noch mal kurz rein
ich habe keinen Anspruch darauf dass
irgendjemand mal sagt okay zweieinhalb
Jahre habe ich es versucht rauszukriegen
ich habe es nicht geschafft aber ich
gebe zu ich bin Mensch genug ich freute
mich wenn das der ein oder andere Mal
über sein Herz bringen
das ist frech der Bundeskanzler sagt ja
einem Untersuchungsausschuss eines
Parlamentes nämlich dem
Untersuchungsausschuss der Freien und
Hansestadt Hamburg des Parlamentes das
er will dass man aufhört und er sagt das
auch den Journalisten die dort sitzen
und die ihm berechtigte Fragen stellen
vielleicht hat ja mal eine Antwort
darauf aber die will halt nicht geben
sondern erfordert dass man aufhört er
will dass der Untersuchungsausschuss
nach zweieinhalb Jahren jetzt ist mal
gut ne
ich habe mich erfolgreich nicht erinnert
jetzt muss man gut irgendwie und ihr
Journalisten ihr könnt ja weiter Fragen
aber eigentlich könnte auch aufhören
kommt nichts mehr raus das gehört sich
nicht macht man nicht ist eine Frechheit
gehört sich nicht macht war nicht
Frechheit ist die elegante Überleitung
zu einer Vorgänger groß sehr schön sehr
schön ja auch zu Gerd Schröder hat oder
40 geäußert
unsere Wirtschaftslage ist ja
gegenwärtig trotz dieser Schwierigkeiten
davon gekennzeichnet dass wir eine hohe
Beschäftigung haben und sie sogar weiter
steigt und deshalb glaube ich haben wir
alle Chancen gut durch diese Zeit zu
kommen auch wenn es schwierig wird erst
war jetzt nicht Scholz kann man nicht
oft genug gar nicht oft genug betont das
war noch mal der Merkel Moment was hat
dazu also zu Schröder gesagt worden auf
Nachfrage von einem Journalisten ob den
Gerhard Schröder noch mal irgendwie
einen größeren Beitrag leisten könnte
für ihn so viel Verhältnis Russland ich
wüsste nicht der Kanzler gesagt das war
dann so eine schöne flapsige das war
schon das witzigste ich wüsste nicht
also quasi total Abfuhr an den alten
Kanzler sollte man Hannover in unserem
Häuschen sitzen und ab und zu mal dann
zum travel fahren aber der Kanzler setzt
nicht mehr auf den Altkanzler vielleicht
der einzige wirkliche schmunzelmoment in
dieser Pressekonferenz danke schön Peter
für deine Einschätzung
[Musik]